this past weekend look man sometimes if
we want to grow we got to start small
let's start with a little tiny sand whoo
[Music]
get that tiny
that's tiny sand whoo he's sending
another beautiful riff right there and
that's that dirty riffraff Ian man
they're frickin riff a Potamus mr. tiny
sand who himself and who is he who is he
we don't know the jury's still out you
know he's an email that hit my inbox and
ever since then the correspondence has
been nothing but sheer fire just sheer
frickin flying's and tiny sand whoo when
he hits that inbox I know I mean dude
it's just like a damn morphine drip and
I want more and more and more and I'm
feigning and fainting and fainting and
I'm more feigning for that tiny sand
whoo and that was him right there
always on the run whoever he is is he a
mother is he a father is he a ah is he a
little wizard
what is he is he made out of paper mache
is he a dragon does he own a dragon what
does he own a cat a pet a circus Mouse
oh this was a little circus mouse
Tommy's hand who could be doing many
things out there but he's choosing to
send in music from the great beyond
whatever he lives in a sand dune where's
he from India Indiana where is he from
what does he drink coffee water syrup
what's he just hiding just what does he
do just hide starbursts under his tongue
all day and just let me get the end just
get that slow melt into his jowls that
just slow secretion of that sugar water
just catching that fire flavor right on
under his tongue what does he do we
don't know he is tiny sand too
let me catch another dab off that riff
go tiny
[Music]
beating that beating that thing like it
like it owes him something that's Tiny's
hand whoo welcome to this past weekend
it is Monday November 20th and I am Theo
von coming to you from Huntsville
Alabama if you're not familiar with
Huntsville it's a place it's a place
down here in northern Alabama and it's
got a unique vibe to it man you know it
has it has it has the largest collection
of pre Civil War homes I don't know if
you know that or not
mansions pre Civil War mansions the that
most of them are here in in Huntsville
it was once the water crest capital of
the world
so if you're into exotic vegetables that
don't really do nothing then then this
might be a place you want to stop in to
but I've had a good time here this
weekend you know I had a good time I
didn't do that much though you know I
really didn't take advantage of my time
as much as I could have so I'm feeling a
little bit less you know less than
cavalier about that you know I could
have been out high horsing you know and
living out there and doing things
locally you know buy an art worker you
know maybe even donating blood or doing
something fancy you know or trying to be
part of the bright arts you know I
didn't do too much man I got caught into
a into a vein of um okay you hear that
train going by you hear that can y'all
hear that train can you hear it maybe
you can't hear but they got a train
going by man I'm right here but the
train tracks is a lot a lot of trains go
through here but yeah I didn't do too
much man you know I took it easy and I
didn't really take care of myself that
great I didn't do no drugs I didn't do
in alcohol but I did get caught up you
know just not doing anything good for
myself not doing anything super positive
I did to do to yoga's yoga's by Adrienne
now if you go on YouTube and you want to
do some yoga and you don't have money to
get to the class or you can't afford a
mat they have a teacher on there yoga by
Adrienne and it's a woman
I think she's single and she is she has
a dog named Benji and they do yoga they
teach you all types of yoga and it's
free right there on the YouTube but I
had a nice time overall had a nice time
man and we got a special episode for you
today we're gonna get into the dark arts
we've been talking about it we've been
talking about emptying our bread baskets
you know of this yeast infection that is
the darkness within us and we're gonna
drop that off outside of the shop you
know so we can mosey around through the
universe with our hearts open you know
you hear that train wood that's what I'm
talking about
this train country I'm here to spend
time around a train but damn boy I mean
if you haven't yet been on the train you
haven't seen much dude you know I used
to take the Greyhound from New Orleans
up to Champaign Illinois when I was 11
and 12 and 13 years old and my brother
and I would ride up on that train with
the Masons and you'd I've always have a
lot of Masons and a lot of black men and
a lot of preachers on there and
preachers families and everybody riding
on there and spending time you know they
had one lady and one of the little train
car or the little you know you could get
a overnight thing and she's in there
selling her body you know selling a
little bit of sex a little train sex and
if he was in all of that then you could
get in all that but that was something
speaking of trains I went and saw
midnight on the Orient Express or
whatever it is Murder on the Orient
Express save your money
all right boring I'd rather take an
Amtrak I'd rather spend $30 on an Amtrak
probably better crime better mysteries
you know if you want to get involved in
a little bit of the Dark Arts you take
an Amtrak because man it is dim it is
dim living in some of those train cars
and some of that environment but good to
be here thank you guys for joining me I
was in Huntsville Alabama these people
loved football did I never seen anything
like it
okay I mean I know I grew up and you
know I went to LSU for a while and
University of Arizona
you know I saw some of these you know
different football schools but I never
saw anything like this
Friday night so I was here Thursday
through Sunday and it's Sunday night
right now and it's about midnight and
I'm dropping this so I can catch that
flight in the morning to head back to
Los Angeles
so I can start celebrating these
holidays because it's turkey time
if you do turkey or if you don't do
turkey whatever
if you vegan if you're not vegan you
regular you unlit it you diabetic you
die in whatever you know show neck long
neck turkey time you know if you like
giblets you like something you like
pumpkin pie coconut cream whatever you
want we got your thing you know we got
all that because it's coming in hot
you're gonna see a family you know we
got a lot of seasonal activity starting
up flaring up but but I was here this
weekend they were and everybody came out
for the football man I mean people came
out and they came out because on Friday
they had this guy named funny mane
Jermaine funny main Johnson and he makes
YouTube videos about Alabama football
right and I'm thinking well yeah you
know people will come they're excited to
see him perform he sold the place out
wall-to-wall to shows people just wanted
to come he would do some comedy you know
he's decent decent decent comedian you
know and and not belittling him I don't
think he would say he's great but then
he would answer questions about you of a
football and man it was people loved it
you know and it was interesting because
he was he's a black man Jermaine funny
man Johnson and it was an all-white
audience for the most part I would say
98% Caucasian and it just it was neat
man it was cool you know just showed me
that there are a lot of things that
bring different races together in the
south you know people always want to
give the South a bad name or you know
give it this racial
you know this darkness to it but I'll
tell you this man this was the bright
arts going on because this man sold 700
tickets you know to see people for
people to come out and listen to him
talk about football so I mean it was
just great to see man it was great to be
a part of it I had to feature I didn't
have to but I they asked me if I wanted
to feature they meant open up for him
so he was headlining Friday night and
man it was a test of it was humility man
you know it put me back in uh you know
because you want to be the headliner you
want to be the main show you want you
know you want to be that big barker you
don't want to be that middle whistle you
want to be that big Barker
you know if you bite and you don't want
to be them front teeth you want to be
them mole ours and he was be he was the
mole ours and I was the front teeth and
so it was a it was a testament humility
at first I didn't like it it didn't feel
well on me it made me feel a a little
bit less than and made me feel
unsuccessful but after I ate swallowed
those thoughts I realized that look I
got a chance to go out here and make you
know five hundred six hundred new fans
that have not seen me perform maybe even
before and and I went out and did it man
you know I just had to swallow my ego
and that was good man I think I needed
that I think we always any chance we get
to to feel some humility
especially in this in this in this me
universe I think it's always pretty
solid so that was good man we had a good
time out there doing those shows and the
South is just different man it's just I
forget what it's like even in some of
these environments I mean this is Bible
Belt right around here this is the damn
buckle you know this is the dang buckle
you know and I love you know and I love
that environment you know I grew up in
some church environments and you know I
love seeing people you know have that as
part of their lives I think it's a great
I think it's a it's great to have the
infusion of a higher power in your life
I don't think you can go wrong with it
so it was nice to be around some of that
you know but man physical fitness
probably second or third on the pendulum
here you know I was going for a jog this
fella pulls up in his truck you know I
asked me if something's wrong I'm just
jogging I was like huh he's like what
you what you running from like running
from diabeetus dude I'm this out here
jogging you know I'm trying to get my
fitness up I'm trying to keep my sugar
down in my lipids low and I'm trying to
get my Fitness up but that was some cool
some good stuff some and some good
activity and we got a bunch of calls
from you guys for the dark arts and so
I'm gonna slowly you know man they're
into those but I do want to thank our
charter sponsor that's gray black pizza
and that's GRE y BL Ock pizza dot-com in
Los Angeles you know I'm saying just
pull over there off Pico Boulevard
headed to the beach stop in open your
mouth and get that hit up get that hit
up
great block pizza man good food for your
face and and I'm feeling ok man I wish I
would have done a little bit more if my
week you know sometimes when I get out
of here on the road I get down in the
dizzies you know I get down in the dumps
you know you're out here you by yourself
you know I mean I guess I'm just
grateful it I didn't you know do
anything stupid cuz I was bored you know
because sometimes out of boredom you can
but that wasn't me this weekend so I can
show some gratitude for that I was gonna
go to the Rocket Center you know they
have a Space and Rocket Center here and
I love astronaut ice cream you know I
mean I go to space just for the nice
crime you know I go to damn orbit just
for the desserts
I love astronaut ice cream if you never
had it as this dried out ice cream comes
in these pouches different flavors and
if you thinking of something getting
Daddy for Christmas well that's what you
can get daddy and I love Christmas and I
love the holidays and it's something you
don't know about me when I was a child
they had Christmas stockings you know
and you know what it is they put Santa
brings them hangs him from something in
your homestead and that's where you get
to candy get the treats get the small
gifts and I love those so much that for
probably about three months after that I
wore Christmas stockings when I was
probably in about maybe third grade I
would wear I got two of them off the
mantel or whatever and I warm in my
shoes doing I warmest socks you know
warm his socks dude I remember a little
league basketball the only dude out
there on the court with two Christmas
sucks - two Christmas stockings in his
in his beak a high tops in his British
nights in his champion shoes you know so
I got high tops bro with them red and
white over you know with them red and
white overhangs bro and that's Christmas
stockings
so you know that I'm that I'm into the
holidays when you know I'm out there on
that court wearing Christmas stockings
going toe-to-toe literally with the
competition so that was something that I
was into as a child and I'm excited man
it's a good week man and I wanted us to
purge some of our some of the negativity
and some of the things some of the dark
arts because we all have them and I'm
gonna get into some of those calls but
first I wanted to do a follow-up you
know last week we talked about do black
men get nervous because trust me I mean
maybe in some places they dud they don't
you know I've seen some some tender
black gentlemen out and on the west
coast and these boys you know look like
they'd never been through a thing in
their life but the black gentleman that
I grew up around it was a different
variety you know and just like in the
south as one play you know it's just
like different places different types of
people you know and it could have just
been in my neighborhood into my town but
but they had some some real warriors
where I was from and I did not see a lot
of nerves in a lot of those gentlemen
but we did get praise Gulag a couple of
gentleman callers that called him that
hit the hotline and and let's crack into
those calls right now
oh but thanks I get this call from
somebody who said thanks for coming to
Huntsville I want to hear that Bama just
want to tell you good luck on your shows
this weekend I can't make it out nights
Thursday maybe Saturday night me and my
wife to come out I gotta find a
babysitter for the kids but welcome to
Huntsville man yeah and I just thought
that was nice and you get a taste of
what the vibe is like down here by
hearing that man's voice that's Lee
right there and you know you know it was
just nice to be around you know people
here really friendly that got called
before before I was even you know he
called Thursday or whatever that was I
don't know when this was Thursday and
said welcome to town you know he
couldn't make it out but he was thinking
about hopefully being able to come out
the rest of the weekend and I don't know
if I met him or not I can't remember if
I did maybe on Saturday night but still
it's just that kind of place where
people they know you're coming they're
gonna call and let you know when it
things that they're happy to you're
coming they're gonna try to get to see
you and you got to hear an accent
locally that's Huntsville accent clients
feel made Huntsville bread Huntsville
alright man let's get into some of these
uh we had some my brothers that called
in and when I say brother I mean
everybody's my brother but this is an
african-american gentleman who called
enemy hit the hotline and in response to
black men getting nerves anxiety etc
let's get that hitter here we go seven
Dayton Ohio Steve Mac over there in
Cincinnati and Steve Mac also is a
comedian as well and Steve Mac thank you
for callin dude I appreciate it
we've spent some fun time together in
the past I made love one time to a
friend years who um you know I think was
a you know we stayed up all night doing
marionette and or whatever some girl
that was on the on and an adult flag
team she was an adult flag team a very
rare breed and uh and I met her and I
believe that we did make love on word
Steve thank you for calling man didn't
have any black callers and I wanted to
call in and give you a little too thin
Thank You Man I appreciate that I'm
black but I'm more like you know like
like call to sack black you know I like
white women coldest egg black that was
the term that he used now I feel you did
they got a lot of cul-de-sac black guys
out and um that I see more on the West
Coast these days all more actually I'm
married to was I wanted to get into this
you said black people being nervous and
confident and I feel like those are come
to completely different things so like
my wife she's from a small white town
like I'm nervous when I go there but I'm
confident enough you know to fit in and
to be okay so everyone I'm nervous to
spot when I go just because I double the
black population but I'm confident
enough to be able to fit in you know and
do that oh yeah man that's all I really
had I appreciate you brother no worries
to you I thought I heard a cow in the
background at some point there I'm not
that's true or not from Cincinnati thank
you for calling Steve so yeah so you
felt that you felt that nerves
so you do feel that nervous but have a
confidence enough to uh to I guess keep
it low
to overcome it to keep it low you know
and maybe that's just a maybe that's the
art maybe that's an art that may lie
within because some cultures some
ethnicities are better at things and
others are different behave differently
under circumcircle stances that's one
thing that I don't like sometimes about
trying to you know make everybody be
equals
like I want everybody to be equal but I
do not want everybody to be the same you
know cuz it's not fun it's not that I
don't see I don't see the I don't see I
think differences is what makes us great
man everybody the same as [ __ ] yeah
everybody could become in suicide man
popping off you know collect him bullets
in their head with their brain maybe one
maybe two and they're gonna be done
because you collect two bullets in your
head with them yeah that's gonna be it
not many people who collect three
bullets in their head I wonder what the
most time someone is trying to shoot
themselves in the in the head and not
been successful with it god I would love
to interview that man let's hear a
little bit more we got another call in
here from a black gentleman and I
appreciate I appreciate it I mean this
made me feel good just to know that we
have a variety of listeners let's hear
more
how you doing Theo von thanks for having
me on who this guy sounds even a little
bit blacker so you bet we're happy to
have you on man thank you you're a funny
man thank you I appreciate that ma'am
trying let me just start by saying that
black white Mexican purple blue water
same we all have the same issues we are
the same problems agreed man I you know
I agree and I think they can probably be
more enhance that certain people's lives
but I agree I think that there's a
there's a lot of commonality homework
but I would be allowed and said if I
never got nervous for anything but
that's never stopped me from doing the
things that I wanted to do or accomplish
what I wanted to accomplish
then there
there but we come too far as of people
for those nerves to hold us back I think
that we should always push forward in
times of despair because we would get it
we would get nowhere if we did let that
hold us back
mmm so I am here to tell you that yes
black people do get nervous and if they
told you that they didn't in their life
thank you for having me on thank you I
appreciate the call they heard it I mean
that guy definitely black you know you
could hear it and I hate some people be
like oh I don't know maybe that God's
not black you know I mean he could be
any color with it look let's be real
about some stuff okay
eighty-eight percent chance that man is
black okay sometime I hate just some of
these things where people are just like
well I don't know huh
you know and I appreciate that
information man but yeah that's
interesting here you come too far to
less something as small as that hold you
back it's captivating man it's
captivating to think about that you know
and to think about what people in
different cultures have gone through and
how over time I bet as a culture and as
a race that you you learn to keep things
like that more subdued you know or to
rise above them easier because sometimes
when you're white nerves just I mean you
know if you've had life easy maybe
nerves it could be the most rattling
thing you know you know we have a lot of
mental health issues here in America and
a lot of that is is basically a first
world problem you know it's like we're
lucky enough to have mental health
issues because we need doing [ __ ] you
know so so many people got so much they
got everything is we just sitting around
stressing you know worried because we're
not staying active but I appreciate that
other call man I really appreciate it
thank you very much everybody who hit
him we had that Thursday episode that
talked more about that do black man get
nervous
and we really we delved into that a
little bit and it's good it's a good
discussion
you know because you heard it there
black men do feel nerves but I'll be
dang if it doesn't seem like they mask
them a lot better than other ethnicities
other cultures and that may be a art
that they have you know and I would even
go on to say that women seem less
nervous a lot of times they might be
show fear easier than men but I might
think that women seem less nervous
sometimes than men and being seem to see
a nerve chart you know get that nerve
chart out that in --see and see how that
beautiful thing breaks down okay guys
this is it we got these dark arts tiny
let me get another look riff from tiny
[Music]
tiny tiny - where are you dude well how
bizarre is it that at some dude tiny
sand who just hits me up and has been
dropping these riffs in man box indeed
you should read his emails like it
doesn't even he barely I don't think
English is his first language so truly
beautiful that's the art the art of the
Internet we got a lot of Dark Arts that
came in
speaking of arts and I want to get into
him and before we go into a man I've
shared some of you know we're coming up
on a year of this podcast December 19th
will be a year I believe and and I just
want to say that I'm thankful coming up
on Thanksgiving and coming to the
holidays I'm so thankful you know one of
my friends Bill Morris the other day
who's a member of the gaunt squad on
that patreon he said you know he said
you didn't know when you started this
thing if you would even still be doing
it you know you didn't know what you
were doing you were nervous and I still
feel those things you know I still feel
nervous but but I feel more excited now
you know I have dudes come up to me at
the shows even this week this weekend in
Huntsville man iscope well y'all fellas
I showed up
and that you know we're just saying hey
man the podcast is you know it means
something to me
you know we out there doing some things
and being naughty you know and being
naughty daughter's even though we got
pain s ass you feel me so I'm just
grateful man I'm feeling a lot of
gratitude right now and I wasn't feeling
that before I even started the episode
tonight so thank you guys for that man
y'all are doing that from me this
evening okay cool man let's get in now
look I'm gonna tell you this this is the
dark arts we're opening up okay this is
Pandora's little panty box we're about
to jump in so some of this stuff man you
might not be prepared for it you know
some of this stuff with this thing this
ain't no sipping tea you know this ain't
no Keurig coffee I'll tell you what my
problem is with I'll tell you what my
problem is with Keurig coffee is that
it's nasty it's not even coffee okay
first of all you know is good and well
mister Keurig that it's hot brown water
dude I'll drink nine Curie's and take a
nap dude you know I'm saying I'll give
cured to a baby because it ain't gonna
do nothing you want some real coffee go
find somebody granddaddy when they had
that cup of that strong CIPA when he
woke up and took that hit up you know
that's the stuff that drip drop it in
drop you had to swallow twice to get a
dram of it down your throat that was
coffee that thick syrupy yangyang
boy I mean that [ __ ] was great that I
mean that [ __ ] would straighten your
granddad his spine scoliosis no Lee OSIS
to two pots of grandmas coffee is what
got the railroads built and curing out
here selling this company cup a little
the pods and you pop them in view French
for eat a dick and make it bag cured you
know you're making [ __ ] and that's
what's wrong with a lot of men in this
country y'all drinking that curing pod
okay get out there get the grounds do
the Pam okay get out there get that
little baby sheet throw the grounds on
it put
the thing turn it shut it bam water time
get that hit up put it in a cup and get
your life done
stay off the Cure that's it's [ __ ]
Keurig is what's turning all these men
into ballerinas these men out there
can't even walk anyone wearing boots
anymore that their tippy-toeing shopping
for carpet drink regular coffee and be a
man that's what I'm saying dude so I
don't mean to get violent there get
fired up but Keurig should be held
accountable this should be a
class-action suit against Keurig for
turning all these men in a straight one
offense this should be a class-action
suit against Keurig for weekend in these
men because that ain't coffee you're
selling that is candy this jumpity water
that's all that is this that's just
jumpity water and it ain't helping but
with that said man I'm gonna hit a
regular ass coffee right here off the
grounds that Folgers you know I'm saying
Folgers man Folgers will keep your hair
Brown not this Keurig [ __ ] you know dude
I had two cups of Keurig woke up wearing
a thong what's going on something isn't
right
drink regular coffee get the grounds get
that little baby get to get the grounds
get that little upside-down baby hat you
feel me
put the grounds in the Hat put it in the
thing water water top closed button wait
[Music]
hot put it in a cup get that hit up
sorry ma'am but that's how I feel all
right man we're gonna give you these
dark arts and summer dark and some are
not you about to find out
all right thank you guys so much for
these calls I love you let's go here we
go
let's purge man let's get it out of our
system let's listen together let's be
together again if you need to hit the
hotline the number is nine eight five
six six four nine
5:03 if you want to grab a shirt there
are tore shirts from all the cities from
this year you can grab them at theof on
comm slash store as always you can get
my album 30 pound bag of hamster bones
or musket fire the early years of satire
both of those are available on iTunes
let's get into these dark hearts here we
go
what's up field this is out what's up
hey tail there's Joe from Tennessee I
was just gonna try to bring up the topic
that I haven't heard you talk about yeah
okay this is Joe from Tennessee thank
you for calling Joe onward yeah
something in the dark guard a little bit
of conceptual situation back when I was
21 years old
my aunt Wanda sucking on my dick so I
got drunk and I let her and then I ended
up [ __ ] her and I don't want to get
into a huge story the whole story I
should say but let me know if you want
to hear it and I could go on with that
but I just want to know what that you
think that was kind of weird but it
wasn't really my blood aunt Wow oh man I
told you it was gonna get dark dude and
people gots the darkness Joe thank you
for calling from Tennessee man I got to
hear this again dude I'm sorry Joe and I
know some of y'all aren't even be able
to hear it again especially if you're in
a car with your wife or if you're a
woman or a female you might have a
tougher time if use a gentle male you
know if he's a tender male who you know
or if you is a premature baby you know
because a lot of people just premature
babies they can't handle things you know
some premature babies they might live to
be 80 years old but they'll never make
nine months you know they'll always be a
little gelatinous and the skeleton Asst
if you know what I'm saying man you know
they'll always have kind of a real soft
neck but let's hear that again Joey Joe
here we go something in the dark guard a
little bit of conceptual situation back
when I was 21 years old my aunt wanted
to suck on my dick so I got drunk and I
let her
and I ended up [ __ ] her and you know
I don't want to get into the huge story
the whole story I should say but I think
that is the whole story Joey I think
that is well look John what you know
there's a safe place to share that kind
of stuff and I appreciate you calling
man let's hear the end of your call so I
know if there's anything else homework
really my blood aunt
it was my uncle's wife she was 35 I was
21 she's hot as [ __ ] so let me know what
you think have a good one see ya
look man everybody been through some
things you know now you had a fine aunt
I mean and that's a gift really from the
heavens above from Zeus and Hera and I
feeling and Jesus Christ and and Allah
and everybody that's up in the clouds
that's a gift having a fine aunt because
a lot of us we sit around the yah you
know family get-togethers and
everybody's busted and that's okay you
know you might have somebody might be
thinking about a little bit softly on
the side but nothing that's really gonna
flare you up well it wasn't your blood
aunt so that's when you said that that
helped that led us all off the hook as
listeners Joey
that led us all off the hook I'll say
this ma'am here's how I can relate to
this for one when I was young you know I
think I was probably you know 10 and I
had a sister that was maybe six and I
remember times where I would hug or
extra like as if she was like a like a
little girlfriend of mine or something
her and I know that sounds weird and I'm
and I never did anything weird you know
but I do remember sometimes thinking she
was like a baby or something of mine you
know and I remember thinking for a long
time that there was something wrong with
me about that but I've talked to her
about it she doesn't have any
recollections of it and then so that
made me feel okay you know I guess my
biggest concern was if she felt
something strange about that so
sometimes I think we all have things
mean I caught my nephew's one time you
know I think they were probably 10 or
9 or 11 and they was in the bed and
laying in there nudity full nudity you
know just you know just rubbing it you
know touching each other's bodies with
each with their own hands you know so I
think some things happen when people are
younger you know I remember I used to
the first time I stayed over at my best
friend's house mr. Scott well his name
was Scott and I call him mr. Scott now
just to make just to have a fun name but
his name was just Scott were both
children and we were laying in a
queen-size bed at his father's house and
going to sleep this was in Mississippi
and his father comes back in the room
after we he shut off the light and he
said now you boys can sleep polled a
pole or hold a hole but no sleeping
polled a hole and hell dude it took us
[ __ ] seven minutes to even figure out
what the hell the deal was we're turning
over different ways and like polled or
what and hold a wood and finally one of
us just slept on the floor we got tired
of doing the math so that was kind of a
wild time but anyway Joe we've all been
through some things man it sound like
you got that keep that heat you know you
cop that hitter from your own aunt and
what's that the part that could be
alarming to me and this might be a
question you is was your aunt always
into you because if she was into you as
a child you know she's looking at you at
nine being like damn who's that [ __ ]
hottie over there about a mashed potato
then that's that's a little bit alarming
on her side you know she might have that
she might be she might be the real dark
artist here but damn it's 21 letting you
uncle's wife drop that freaking face on
you on your place if you know that's
unbelievable dude and I appreciate you
calling a sharing with us you sound okay
about it itself sound like you're
driving a vehicle so you must have a
license you know you didn't say that you
had a big falling out but then you
escalated it to that next level and took
it on the six so damn John Reid in order
to say Joe if you want to call back in
and give a little more to that story
minim I don't know if we'd like to hear
it or not I think we
would though you know this is a safe
place you can share the dark hearts man
and that's that's definitely one of the
dimmer arts that I've heard but I
appreciate you sharing it man I mean
things happen man all right let's take
another call here we go differently Alex
Vaughn thank you for calling from
Lafayette Louisiana you brought up what
kind of Dark Arts we face and I have to
say the biggest art artists we face in
our everyday lives is the political Dark
Arts everyone wants to classify
themselves as on the left or the right
when in reality all that is a bunch of
[ __ ] okay I appreciate you calling
Alex it sounds like a it sound like you
wrote this down before you called but
that's okay man that's okay I appreciate
it
onward I think we need to go back to
loving each other as Americans and get
through problems we faced together with
logical thinking what are your thoughts
on the political spectrum turning into a
back-and-forth lynching that isn't
helping anybody I think most of the back
and forth lynching on politics is done
on social media and it's done and it's
and it's done that's what I think it's
done I think it's on social media I
think in real life the truth is things
are pretty much going okay you know
think about it things are going
nothing's any different now when Trump
sent off as someone Obama wasn't office
can you I mean what I'm really what my
everyday life is like it's the same it's
the same you know I do I think that um I
think that change is always good and
that you got to go through tough times
to get to better times
I don't think politics has ever served
any of most of America you know I think
we have the same problems we had 40
years ago in this country 50 years ago
in this country you know and I think
that if if we can find a way for I hope
the kind of hope most of the system
comes crashing down somehow and we find
a way we look into ourselves because you
know if you're thinking that these
politics are gonna save your life or
save your soul I mean they're not gonna
do anything for you that's just my
thought you might think differently you
know but yet people are at odds about
this kind of stuff
you know and I find most of the ad odds
and it's a regional you know and a lot
of that's based on perspective but I
think a lot of people are getting duped
you know I think you work hard you get
your life done you move forward I think
that's all that we can control and I
think that the good thing is about this
political time is that the dark arts
that are around us is that it shows us
that the light that we have is a light
you better turn on for yourself because
if you're sitting around thinking that
you know $400 or $700 a month
you know from the government or $4,000 a
year extra is gonna change a universe
man you could be stuck in that same
world forever you know it's about
finding the happiness on ourselves you
know and I'm just by working hard and
moving forward and so I think a lot of
us are realizing that at these politics
they don't matter you could put a
[ __ ] monkey and our juggling monkey
and all in the rid this still be the 1%
still we run in the world and the rest
of us are still just be doing our best
so [ __ ] them you know what we do we just
do we work hard and we take care of
ourselves and we take care of our own
and you try to come and mess with our
own and that's when it gets live maybe
but I appreciate you calling in about it
let's hear about a little more dark RTC
on us there's some good ones guys
there's some good ones here we go Rico
from that New Hampshire boy camp City
dude camp games strong and that reminds
me um this past weekend was the last
date of my ham panini Zee tour we hampt
out you know I got one more date in
Calgary December 1st at Cowboys but
that's not part of the tour that's just
a regular comedy show but I think
everybody who came out and supported
this year and got one of the shirts
online or did anything to support and I
want to thank my boy sure who does the
audio every night of this podcast I keep
forgetting a thank him
I'm so grateful to your brother this
this gentleman allows me at 1:00 a.m. or
whenever to send me audio file to send
him an audio file and he helps out and
gets it onto the web for us so I'm so
grateful to him and Ken Highland who's
been doing a lot of the editing thank
you guys very much
homeward calling about the dark arts
what gets me is who
who gives me more than anything else
more than the devil's lettuce but it's
just food man and it was it was a lot
due to my mom my mom was a very lady and
loved to eat and and turn I love to eat
she was a big Baker and loved to bake
and it just seemed like there was always
something sweet something sugary
something cakey something I don't know
to snack at at my house and that's what
I still not that I deal with it because
it's way worse thing to deal with and
the world and I know it's all there's
there are levels but I do deal with one
they eat food every day and I have lost
weight and I am feeling better than I
used to but it's still I feel a daily
struggle now I appreciate you calling in
about this man you know I haven't had
that you know I haven't had that same
that same struggle appreciate you you
know shining a little bit of light on
the fact that a dark art can come out of
anywhere you know a dark art can be that
you collect snakes you know that you do
in food you do an extra food you know
that you hide and snacks and your shoes
or snacks under your you know you
[ __ ] putting kool-aid powder in your
water bed and sticking a straw in it
sometimes when nobody's looking you know
we're being wild like that or doing
whatever you know we're hot and sugar
cubes under your and your damn you know
putting them where your eyeballs you
know that skin in front of your eye
whatever that is pulling that open and
stuff and sugar down in there by your
eyeball you know it could be anything
you collecting lasers or you know
pornography watching too much
pornography you know masturbate not into
the street or whatever masturbating in
your friend's car or sleeping in your
friend's trunk at night and jerking off
in there and leaving you underpants in
there you know it could be anything to
be looking at naughty things on the
Internet you shouldn't be looking at you
know it could be getting a you know some
oral sex from you and and then taking it
all the way to town you know she gonna
flirt weak on the skirt you know taking
it there
but but it's it's interesting to know
that it can be food man and that it came
from an influence you had in your own
house with your mother it was more of a
thicker were lady and I hope that's not
an offensive term to use with you and
you had snacks man I'll tell you this
dude my mother was so thin growing up
you know she's thin lady and we never
had a lot of food around the house and
did I remember going over to friends
houses and if they had a cinnamon roll
or something like that on the counter
man it made me man it just made me think
that they were so lucky you know there's
something about a baked good that made
to me it was just and it could have been
advertising that got me believing all
this stuff but it made me feel like you
know there was love in the house or
something you know if it's half a pie
they're sitting there wrapped up and
everybody hadn't eaten all of it then it
means that there's people are
comfortable enough people are fed enough
you know so I was envious and I would
see that at friends houses you know when
I would see a half a pie you know just
out on the counter be there all night it
would be there in the morning if I
stayed overnight I'd be like damn nobody
ate that pie all night you know they
must everybody here must be satiated and
everybody here must be comfortable
because we never had that man we never
had you didn't see anything left out on
the counter nothing you know and always
was so envious when I would see that out
of the people's houses that to me it was
a symbol of comfort in their home but I
appreciate you sharing with us that that
wasn't really for you and I'm intrigued
about how this is it you know like how
this could relate with you and your
mother let me hear a little bit more and
it is a dark arts that work on my brain
and I know a lot of other people so
thanks to this podcast thank you for let
me hump it I deal with it because it's
way worse thing to deal with and the
world and I know it's all there's there
are levels but I do deal with one eat
food every day and I have lost weight
and I am feeling better than I used to
but it's still I feel a daily straw
and it is a dark arts that work on my
brain and I know a lot of other people
so thanks to this podcast
thank you for yeah Thank You Man thank
you for that call you know I haven't had
I haven't had it somebody introduced
that as the dark art I know what we're
just talking about this house wanted to
hear again we exactly what you said you
know and I guess yeah you know it's
interesting that that being around and
you know your mother had the affliction
then you caught it you know it's
interesting I would use different things
to satiate ourselves you know it could
be food could be masturbation you know
it could be wearing too many scarfs
you know I know I got a friend up you
know this girl she started wearing
glitter and doing the tanning beds you
know and now did every time I see that
[ __ ] that that that chick she looks
like a damn [ __ ] uh I mean she looks
like a damn recyclable good she looked
like she made out of aluminum she have
so much glitter on her it's crazy dude
she look like one of those people that
works in the French Quarter in New
Orleans you know with a dinner on the
boardwalk in Venice in California you
know she got so much glitter on her it
looked like you know a can collector my
Turner in for a couple bucks
she just looks glittered up too much you
know like she might get you know like
she gonna try to get hot like like the
Silver Surfer is gonna try to [ __ ] her
you know what I'm saying like it's not
good but yeah we all have our
afflictions man I appreciate you showing
us that that can be a dark art and wish
you the best man you know I think it's
just like anything it's like when I get
down at night you know and I feel that I
feel that vulture inside of me just
lands his talons on my [ __ ] oh my my
clavicles you know when it just says you
know it that it wants to do something
wrong and that can be anything man that
can be you know looking at pornography
or thinking about my aunt you know or or
thinking about getting a hearty snack
you know a man I'd have been so envious
of being at your house and having those
snacks around but I'm sorry that that a
flight effective flicked at you that way
and and and thank you for sharing that
with
man I'm sure other people go through
that as well so thank you for opening up
that box all right let's hear some more
here we go calling in kind of recent fan
of yours thank you for the fan [ __ ]
onward brother I had recently had a
sexual encounter in the Greater Los
Angeles area
oh you got that you got a little bit of
knock knock over in the GLA huh all
right let's hear it it was a cute girl
we ended up getting an air B&B somewhere
dude every dude always says it's a cute
girl you know what I'm saying cuz no
dude wants to be like you know I was
hooking up with this you know this you
know this fricking gutta muppet you know
I was hooking up with this fricking you
know this secondhand citizen but maybe
not actually some people say they you
know hooked up with because the only
people only go to like a six
you're like a six to ten that's all
they're the whole range is everybody
even just being human you're a six so
unless it's your aunt that might be a
five bra I don't know just I don't know
if I don't know at the family level can
go past five all inward let's you're
more sorry brother it was a fun weekend
we felt like in art gallery and stuff
like that and this is this is a kind of
no--nor over the internet for a little
bit and listen to that term does he I've
never heard that exact term but I've
kind of known her over the internet it's
interesting how we like to us that's
like getting to know somebody it's just
that's what's normal today okay so you
met this girl over the Internet you guys
got an Airbnb in the Greater Los Angeles
area you had a little bit of that knock
knock you know she copped a little bit
of yo hit uh let's hear more we finally
met up and you know went out did our
thing came back to the Airbnb anyways
we're kind of 30 so we go in the shower
I go in the shower she comes in there
you know she gets on top of me and we're
doing sex that way y'all doing sex and
that water time dude that's that humid
air that's that humid sex you know
and I don't know how people have sex in
a pool anytime I see people having sex
in a pool I'm like that's not realistic
but I like hearing this activity let me
hear more the hell I'm sprung up a
little let's go
water's running we boarded that position
flip over and as I'm standing up this
hour the waters hitting my back on such
a way where it's running down my back
through my ass and off of my balls and
kind of much like its peak honor okay so
you got the water running down your back
through your bottom crack through your
crevasse and off healed balls and kind
of going on to her that's uh that's a
Cincinnati baptism right there boy you
know that dude that's that Andy Dalton
onward she begins to open her legs and
ask me put it in her okay and he said
ask me to urinate in her you know that's
that old giving her the magic dragon
let's hear a little bit more Wow I kind
of lost for words and kind of chuckled
it off and and I was like oh you're
you're funny you're silly and your silly
she's not a juggler brah you know I'm
saying she Shauna she ain't putting
stickers on your neck you know you know
she's not like a um she's not silly
she's not trying to tickle you that
ain't a riddle bro that's straight-up
urine dude that's great a urine
you know that's body wine you know
that's that bladder Cabernet bro and she
trying to freaking catch some of that
off of you let's hear a little bit more
yeah we do our thing but I don't know if
I should keep talking to the girl after
that remind you this is our first sexual
experience yeah Wow
first sexual experience is that what
depends on what you want ma'am if you
want to get to that far to the far
lengths of it all then you might want to
go on further with her you know but if
you want to tone it back and just have
something a little bit more comfortable
you know that maybe that's not the girl
for you but if you want to get into the
dark arts cuz look here's the thing man
Edgar Allan Poe all right he was a dark
artist you know it's sometimes you got
to get in you can get into them but I'm
just saying when you get the more you
wade into the dark arts and that
darkness gives more and more or higher
on your body then it's gonna cover you
up and that's when you're subdued
brother and that's when you'll fall
victim to anything you know next to no
you next thing you know you're out there
you know talking to family members on
the side you know texts and family
members late at night about sensuality
you know like you know like that wild
nephew out the gate you know next thing
you know you're out there at night you
know looking in the distance you know
watching you know animals be wild to
each other on the Internet's and things
like that you know you draw pictures of
animal [ __ ] on your [ __ ] own
driveway with young and Yona in your own
garage door
you know if lipstick and [ __ ] like that
and being in the darks so I'm just
saying you monitor it man
because only you know how dark you're
getting until the cops show up you know
or until your ISP shows up on a hit list
or something you know I'm one of those
um you know stranger danger websites or
something it's all fun and games to that
you know that's like Louie man Louie CK
Soph you know it's all fun and games for
him until he till he gets till he gets
caught up you know and then he's having
a you know uh
you know he's having higher magicians
and jerk off and their hats or whatever
he was doing you know and the next thing
you know he ends up on the sex offender
website registry or whatever it is
I think registries are for weddings but
all right let's hear a little bit more
here we go yo field to Boyd frenzy up
here on British Columbia Canada
princey up there from BC and BC in
America is a headache powder princey but
um you know game recognize game let's
hear more cat daddy on that West Coast
loving you up here man super awesome
hearing you what can help us some young
fellas I just want to give my two cents
yep I appreciate you two cents man
and uh and I don't know what the
exchange rate on two cents is from here
to Canadian but I will say this that
that we're happy that you called and I
want to hear it and thank you for being
on this dark arts episode as we roll
through these dark arts calls keep going
princey I've been an alcoholic for a
long time
but highly functional you know run my
own business do my own thing I said to
[ __ ] my head a little bit so what I
did I just slowed down man sometimes you
don't have to quit the whole works right
you just got to slow it down and it
helped a lot for me then and I just
wanted to let everyone know you know I
mean sometimes you don't have to end
that problem you just got to put a halt
on it you know keep doing what you do
today oh thanks Francie I appreciate it
and he's right
some time you don't have to quit the
whole works sometimes you just need to
put a halt on it you know sometimes you
got to slow it down something you to
apply the brakes but I think most of
what we're talking about here and being
about and I think you're even saying it
- princey is just about recognition
about taking a look at what's going on
you know about sharing with one another
and letting that darkness out of our
lives you know whether you got a man
that's addicted to bad gets out there on
them baked goods on that food addiction
or whether you got some fella that's
just urinating in strange women and air
being bees you know whether you got some
fella that's trying to you know put a
dick dip into the jaw of his aunt you
know or whether you got somebody that's
you know out there
I don't know doing whatever you know
everybody have a dark heart and it's
sometimes it's an addiction and
sometimes it's an affliction but what it
is is about recognizing it and also
recognizing that we're not alone and I
appreciate you calling in and princey
and he's an alcoholic but he slowed it
down and for now and him and maybe
always he feels like he has it under
control and I appreciate you sharing
that let's hear more another dark artist
on this special dark art episode as we
get ready for turkey time that cranberry
dressing Oh that cranberry dressing hey
Josh out here in Charlotte you were
talking about up Josh over there in
Charlotte and I'll tell you this Josh I
was in Charlotte one time and I've been
there for maybe 19 minutes at my hotel
down there downtown and the McCormick
and Schmidt's is down there across the
street and that's a steak house meat
establishment
so I walked over there you know I'm
thinking to myself I'm gonna give me a
little hitter out here right I'm gonna
give me a little ribeye or some kind of
outside hitter and I'm I sit on the
porch and catch that catch that food get
me a giblet fill up you know get my
Gible burnt so I order something I'm
sitting there and I see a black
gentleman go by with a baby carriage and
the man have on a nice hat and I'm
thinking you know I'm from if you saw a
black dude with a baby carriage he
usually selling something you know he
had a you know he's selling toasters or
something like that but then I look
closer I'm like damn this dude the
snazziest looking man I've ever seen
pushing a very very attractive baby
carriage and it was mr. Cam Newton
Cameron Newton pushing his newborn son
alizée I think is the baby's name but he
was pushing his son around so pretty
cool to see man and I'd been in that
town maybe 19 minutes from Charlotte but
let's hear more thank you for calling
people calling in doing the dark arts
and it made me think of about a year ago
I said one of my best friend's mom and
and she's married Wow Wow
let's hear more slept with his best
friend's mother let's hear more ha felt
really bad about that like for two
different ways because I slept with a
married woman and me my best friend's
mom yeah I can imagine man I'm sorry
that uh the yetee go through that I
appreciate you calling us sharing that
and let's hit let's hear more man let's
finish it up but then I did it again and
I felt even worse but I don't know I
think that's pretty dark Artie
dude that's dark art right you might be
dark Arthur do you might be sir dark
arcs sir dark arts a lot kick them nasty
darkness
baby got arts you know dude you that's
why man you slept with your best
friend's mother felt bad about it and
did it again and you know what I think
that's a perfect example
that's a perfect it's almost a
definition of what it is to be caught up
in them DA's you know to be caught in
the deep end of your own emptiness when
that's what we doing because every bet
everybody have a best friend that had
that hot mama you know and everybody
thinking they wishing that she'd come by
and throw a little bit of leg you know
dropping a little limb up in you you
know drop a little bit of limb up in you
in you on your on your swim you know
that she thought that you she'd let you
she'd let you take your limb for a swim
if you know what I mean
but that's wild man you were like that
damn hmm and you know what I honestly do
part of me got me thinking man
she probably find breath I mean I
remember the one of the first woman I
was ever attracted to was one of my
friend's mother's hell did I remember
this my best friend the first time I
ever saw some real cooter real life
American cooter was I was at my best
friend's house and his mother was a
vacuum addict she would vacuum forever
and she was walking down the hall she
kept her place spotless had a spotless
home you know I mean he'll if I was
sleeping over there she'd make the bed
with me in it that was just the way she
liked to do life and I remember she was
walking down the hall she had on a
t-shirt
and she bent over to pick something up
and man she hadn't had about bang-on and
I sure buy it was shirts only at their
house that day I guess because dang you
know I'm saying suddenly I was on crotch
watch and I didn't expect it and that
was wild man and then I remember
sometimes you know fantasizing about my
buddy's mother dude you know it's you
know eye color you know my one of my
friends I remember being over this house
one time and you know nabbing a couple
pairs of his mother's of his mother's
underwear bra damn I got me thinking
about my own afflictions you know but I
never made forever made love to a buddy
of mine to a friend of Mines mother you
know and that's wild bro but I
appreciate you sharing that let's hear
more I don't know if anything
you never had something like that
happened to you or you ever done
something like that
you touch my crotch just thinks for
itself but uh I don't know yeah man
that's what it is I think you know
that's what it is that's that that's
that affliction within us you know
that's our brokenness that's something
in us that make us do that and sometimes
it could be at a certain age it can just
be you know our that's your nature you
know when you got the the toils of
humanity and of young lust bubbling up
in you I mean dude I remember mine when
I was young my dick could be awake for
an hour before I ever was you know I
mean that thing was all about that spout
you know and I remember yeah I
distinctly remember first woman ever
tracked you to a friend of mine buddy
mines mother you know I used to think
about her erotic Lee you know and have
been doing erections and stuff to her
not to her physically but in my
imagination a little bit you know or to
you know be thinking about her you know
one time I saw yeah she had a pair of
Underpants and she'd have had him in a
show and I took them things man and kept
them you know and I used to wear him
around my neck sometimes at night while
I slept and that's dark well that's the
dark arts maybe man and some of that's
growing up some of that's coming in he
owns you know coming in the own skin you
know when you laying in bed at night
with a friend with a buddy with your
with your buddies mother's Underpants I
run a run your neck and you being
naughty like that like a naughty cat day
man we are defunct we are defunct as
humans I appreciate you calling man you
know I think I mean I and you know I
don't even know if I would tell my
friend about that I think that that's
one of those things because here's when
you tell somebody about something if
it's gonna hurt them you don't tell them
and I don't know if your friend knows or
not but I don't know if I let my friend
know that you know but damn boy used up
their getting some cut up that's that's
why oh boy
and that's wild and that's real talk and
that's a real boy out there doing that
let's hear a little bit more
hey this is Steven from Atlanta
giorgia let me see yeah so my dark art
you're talking about dark arts and yet
we are Steven thank you for calling from
Atlanta Georgia that's Peachtree that's
peach peach City the Peach City peach
peach area let's hear more then purging
those before the holidays I like that
idea
mine is actually being a workaholic so
my family will be you know gather around
the table at Thanksgiving like praying
before the meal and then we eat and just
kind of hang out my brother plays guitar
but yeah I have a hard time during the
holidays like man I'm like getting
nervous right now
hey that's okay about getting nervous
man sometimes you know when you call
this hotline if it's a weird call or
someone want everybody to know that if
you give a call and it's weird it's
awkward I'm just gonna pass it by you
know so you know you could mess up five
times you know I just want you to call
and get your your thoughts comfortably
out and I appreciate you calling brother
let's hear more about you know you
feeling like a workaholic
because yeah this is it's important to
me like I feel kind of disconnected from
my family and I feel like my workaholic
workaholism is kind of like a an anxious
thing where it's like I can't slow down
and like appreciate my family there yeah
man it sounds like you have a trouble
being in the moment you know because you
want that you want to do the next thing
what's the next thing what's the next
thing because you can't sit by yourself
something mean you want to go
that's discomfort that's just a built-in
discomfort and and some of that is just
mindfulness man you know you want you
keep wanting to escape the moment that's
what it sounds like to me I can relate
to this fully and personally let's hear
more when they're all there with me it's
like in my head I'm like out in the yard
raking leaves are just doing some type
of type of task it's like I'm so task
oriented and like detail-oriented which
is good for projects but when it comes
to
the simple things in life like having a
conversation it's like I it's like I
can't do it man I can really really
relate to this dude I come really it
would always have to do something else
whatever needed to be going on then
involved like people or interpret it
could be just a conversation I couldn't
listen I would have to pretend like I
was listening cuz my brain will be like
let's go let's talk to that girl or
let's go uh you know if maybe bum a
cigarette or let's go get a drink get
somebody a drink or you got to go home
or anything anything other than a moment
a real moment because then I get to the
next thing I wanna go do something else
you know oh let's go talk to this girl
this girl oh now this girl that I've
always liked likes me but oh guess what
but I'm halfway through a conversation
where she's interested and then I gotta
go talk to somebody else now I gotta go
do this I've got to get out you know and
it's all it just always had to do
something else I got to go
you know I'd be at the best party be
like damn I start texting people do
where's the party even though I'm at the
party it's just feeling uncomfortable
not being able to stay in an actual
moment and I'd do that too and I knew
you're talking about a more in a
personal level with family like you're
having a relaxed moment and you can't
stay there and some of that's just about
comfort ability you know and mindful
just being in the moment that you're in
not being in the past not being in that
next moment nothing has to be done let's
hear more and like I just kind of I just
kind of withdraw you know so yeah I just
kind of wanted to get that off my chest
I love the show and Happy Thanksgiving
thank you happy Thanksgiving to you too
man I'm gonna stay in California for my
Thanksgiving so I'm gonna get to see my
family so I'm a little bit bummed about
that but I will be spending time with
some friends and some people that I care
about so I'm excited about that but I
want to think about this a little bit
more man I think you know just the idea
of having to escape the moment when
moments are real and I do that a lot man
even if I'm spending time with a young
lady or some that I care about all you
know if I'm just sitting in a moment
I'll be like oh is that you know say I'm
sitting at home on my couch you know you
know with a girl that I care about a
girl I like and the second things get a
little bit you know we're talking or
gets I'll be like oh is he is it too hot
in here is it too cold in here you know
they I gotta just the air conditioner I
have to you know adjust the lighting or
let's watch a movie you know just
something when there's actual like real
intimacy when there's a real moment I
can't stay there I just have to do I
have to do something and that's a dark
art man and eventually for me that but
that dark art it became I had to just
keep doing something until I was doing
you know something bad to myself you
know until I was doing a drug or and you
know until I was doing you know cocaine
by myself at home and I'm not saying
that dude I'm making it sound like
that's where you're gonna end up that's
not it at all but for me that's where my
uncomfortability to be able to accept a
moment it led me to that I mean
obviously you know now I'm not doing
that you know now I'm I'm on that sober
train I'm coming in almost maybe a year
and a half now but for a while you know
it just that's where it led me man when
I couldn't be in the moment there was
something uncomfortable and I think the
way you that one of the ways that I
would learn to to solve that would be
just stay take a couple of deep breaths
and just stay in the moment it's the
same thing when I get caught up like I
want to go you know do masturbation or
smoke assay those types of things when
I'm gonna go do something I want to do
something you know want to do something
but that demeans myself or that'll bring
me shame I want to do something that
that I don't need to do instead take a
couple breaths and use them fine man I
bet if you could develop brother but if
you could develop a little bit of a
system of like okay I'm just gonna take
three or four breaths
it ought to be big crazy breasts for him
but he's like damn that [ __ ]
really you know he's over there he's you
know with Hufflepuff you know he and in
Gryffindor no more that dudes you know
that dudes long end up over there you
know he's getting his jollies off on
that on on that on that oxygen on that
o2 you don't have to be taking huge
breaths or puffing like a you know like
a tired Panther but what I'm singing is
that you can just take a couple of
breaths and sometimes that stuff will
pass man you know and that's what
meditation and stuff you know that kind
of stuff can help but I noticed that the
happiest people are the ones that can
stay in a moment they can just stay
there you know they don't have to leave
it now and you will get it will get
easier you know I noticed it with my own
mother man I used to have a problem
hugging my mother I could hug her but it
never felt really real you know and my
whole life it never really has but there
was one time I was at my sister's house
and my mom gave me a hug I gave my mom a
hug and I just kept hugging her and it
was so awkward neither one of us had
ever done that and we just stayed in
this hug for like about thirty seconds
and slowly some of the whatever little
barriers that have been there they kind
of fell a little and it's still kind of
uncomfortable in a hug my mother but
it's not this is as bad as uncomfortable
as it used to be you know but yeah man
just try and work through that you know
try and stay in the moment you recognize
it and that's huge bro
and I wish you the best and I appreciate
you calling on that let's hear another
dark heart call we're gonna get through
these were almost done you know hey Josh
thank you for calling
Houston World Series champs honestly I'm
a little concerned about you you know
okay I mean here you concern Joshua yeah
I've been busting out late
rubbing it out well I don't know when
you heard that podcast but man you know
I'll be a be lyin if I started in a
flick to myself with the you know with
the old Devils um with the old with the
old Devils grip in the past few days
onward know a couple years ago you know
I wasn't bussing out enough wasn't
blessing that almond blessing that pecan
and started getting backed up the old
prostates are getting too big you know
too much fluid in they're not getting it
out and started having problems hmm
so what's a urologist and you know was
having trouble peeing kind of sprinkling
out not a good heavy flow and started
having issues urologist said need to be
busting out once a day minimum you can't
let that thing get backed up man
you can't deny your biology look I
appreciate this call man I feel you you
know I think I don't think it's a
problem masturbation and there's two
schools of thought on that you know some
urologist will say yeah you need to take
care of yourself and some will say no
you don't need to you know that
overdoing it isn't good for you you know
that a lot of things can happen and I'm
really helpful you know you can have
lower you know you can have more
depression you know you know you can be
more or less stressed out I mean there's
different schools of thought on it but
yeah look if people want to drop that
almond do you know people want to
freaking pop that cashew out do that
thing
catch that nut you know I'm not saying
that it's bad for everybody but I'm
saying if the affliction happens or you
it becomes an addiction and you're using
it as an escape you know then I don't
think that it's that healthy and I've
said that before and I'll say that again
that I don't care if you uragan off
outside of a bus window you know cuz
everybody used to do that when I was
growing up but if if you're doing it
repeatedly and you feeling shame about
it then there's some kind of disconnect
let's hear a little bit more hey yo
what's going on brother everyone the
road rolled and I was a young pup I just
wanted to say thank you for the show man
I recently started listening and it's
man that make me laugh thank you thank
you keep up the good work thank you
again thank you man I appreciate that
thank you
you know you're welcome dude I'm just
trying to be of service here and vehic
just a little bit of a conduit and so we
can make this thing even you know just
make it so everybody can get involved
and a place where we can share you know
and I know I'm not doing that much
sharing tonight personally from the
heart I'm trying to and I know this is a
bad excuse but it's just late it's late
for me I should have got in this earlier
today but to be honest man I mean
[ __ ] really I should have done more
this weekend you know and I didn't dude
you know I slept a lot I felt down about
myself you know I ended up springing out
you know I just shouldn't take care of
myself as good as I should have and then
next you know it was Sunday and
thankfully today I got it together you
know and I think I think having you guys
to do this for and with you know kind of
helps me get it together because if not
maybe I'll just roll through another you
know another night you know just not
taking good care of myself you know but
instead you know ablai around feeling
shameful because I didn't you know
because I was doing things I didn't want
to be doing instead I'm up I'm talking
with you guys and we're sharing our dark
hearts and we're working through them
together so you're welcome brother I
appreciate that we got a couple more
calls here and rolling right through a
man and these are some good ones here we
go hey Theo this is John for me
hey John from Maine I went to Maine one
time one of my best friends aunt was uh
lived up there and we went up there
and I fell in love with a girl up there
and I um and it was nice and I remember
I had a cool hat we found a neat hat up
there
and and it was fun man and it was
beautiful and it was the first time that
I felt like I was in another world even
though I was still in in America we had
a nice time a lot of whites up there too
onward I just watched your podcast the
Thursday one and towards the end there
you're talking about you know the fear
of men at this time and whatnot so this
is a bit of a personal experience ended
up getting enough a spot of trouble with
our local authorities due to the revenge
porn law okay so you got a spot of
trouble due to the revenge porn law Wow
yeah I know that I've heard that before
you know if you use or post pornography
pornography type stuff of I guess
someone that you are not in a or at all
then it can cause an issue but let's
hear more on word at the time I was
myself consumed with the dark arts and
kind of buted as a prank put a picture
of some girls tits on the internet haha
whatever Internet tits yes she knows
some of them home word but you know they
had me all over the local news this is
small town [ __ ] so you know how
people are
everybody was [ __ ] making it out that
was some kind of pedophile [ __ ] and to
be able to go the year older than me
and I'm 28 so what okay the girl was
year older than you and you're 28 so
yeah but the small town can make out to
be a pedophile for anything you know I
mean I run one time I was uh I went to
see my girlfriend not a stole a child's
bike one time to get over to her place
cuz I don't have a vehicle because I was
young and so I stole a child's bike a
young girl so I'm riding this little
children's bicycle when they you know
next thing you know you know I go to my
ladies I come back they bust me you know
they got these the cops seeing all this
lipstick and everything and a little bit
of like uh you know some vanilla lotion
and stuff on my neck and he's asking
what's up and I'm talking about my
girlfriend and then he see me on this he
said I got this children
and they was asking me if I was in a you
know being naughty with children and
pedophiles type of stuff and no no I was
not so yeah sometimes small towns man
they will connect the dots even when
there is and even when those dots should
never know each other let's hear more
whatever you know I felt like [ __ ] but
you know after that I went through some
[ __ ] and I'm not much of a religious
person but my friends my friend's mom
was like yeah the we're in the time of
Revelations where everyone's Dark Arts
was gonna start getting revealed so I
just think it's kind of odd that she
said that and all this [ __ ] starts
coming out or out of these Hollywood
types but you know I'm not much of a
Christian and gonna got my own belief
system going but yeah man I just had to
shed away the dark side I'm a much
better person for it and I don't hate
myself for the mistakes that I've made
Wow I love that last statement there I
don't hate myself for the mistakes that
I've made and that's really I mean
that's huge you know cuz for a lot of my
life I think I've carried you know shame
and disgust of myself even when I didn't
know that I did even when I didn't know
that I was doing that and I think I
still do you know carry a lot of shame
and those are things that I'm working
through you know some of the programs
and things that I'm involved with and
working with a sponsor and stuff like
that to try and get myself in a better
way so I'm you know some operating at
full bore because I know that my higher
power has put a lot of gifts inside of
me and I know that he's put a lot of
gifts inside of you you know and we do
get caught up in all this [ __ ] out
here and we get roped in and we get
caught in these nets and in these
uncertainties and we're you know it was
a lot of us are were wired poorly as a
child we didn't have the affection or
the care or the safe environment to
express ourselves and so we're still
fighting through a lot of that you know
and a lot of it is that that is our dark
arts we're still fighting through a lot
of that or feeling some of that or you
know we're just have this reverb of
uncomfort inside of us that makes us
behave certain ways
and you know and we try to get through
that and we get through that together
man you know we get through that by
sharing about telling people what's
going on and to get to a place one day
where we don't feel bad about the
choices that we've made because if we're
not winning we're not living in the past
with regret or carrying an invisible but
tangible regrets around on our shoulders
or in our in our cells or in our neck or
in our system in our spine or in our
nerves and then we can really really be
free you know and I think that that's a
nice goal and I'm sorry you had to go
through that man you know but it sound
like you're in a better place now and I
appreciate you sharing that with us you
know we've all done things man
you know we've all done things and
sometimes we got to get there you know
we sometimes we got to get at the bottom
so we could see where the ladder is at
you know and it's not like you just had
some had a dip but now you back and I
appreciate sharing that with us let's
hear a little bit more man we got one
more call and then we had a brief
message that came in and I'm gonna read
that and then we'll be we're gonna
settle up here we go hey buddy I've been
calling from California hey Jason from
California let's hear a little bit more
you asked for us to call in and talk to
you about the dark art and that's
something that I talk about all the time
I work as a coach and as a trainer for
about 40 people full-time and what I've
come to realize is that you know when we
were born as little kids we were given a
name we were given an ego and I think
that's kind of what the original sin is
as we start to perceive ourselves to be
these separate people there is an
inherent pain that comes from that from
because it's not true okay so what are
you saying is that we were born you know
you're given a name you know you're
given a you you know you're given a name
you're given and you an ego is created
with that name because you start to
develop a sense of self of yourself
outside of everyone it's not like hey
now you're part of everyone it's like
hey now you're Larry in
onward we you know we know we've heard
that spiritual thing that we are all one
we are all connected and believing that
we are separate people is the opposite
part of that and so inherently it's a
it's a false spot and so there's a boom
that comes with believing that you are
the separate person and I think the dark
arts is how each of us deals with our
payment
some people use drugs some use alcohol
some people become apples and they use
power but I think every single person
eventually finds a way to deal with
their pain Wow wow what a captivating
idea man what a great concept you know
that the fact that we are raised and we
are so we are given we are established
as a self instead of as part of
something bigger than ourselves that
that is an affliction and that we are
fighting that and the discomfort of not
being part of something of the whole
thing part of a whole and that is our
dark art let's hear more absolutely find
a way to deal with their pain they have
to to survive and that is what almost
all of us and so that's why the path of
salvation is usually God because as we
come to understand God we come to
understand the personal peace and
personal pleasure and personal joy is
actually out of highest when we are
serving the whole organism when we are
13 to one and so it's being unselfish
that actually it's not Wow
and I know you're hearing the word God
there a lot and that sometimes you hear
that word to turn some people off but
let me tell you this it can mean higher
power it can just mean something outside
of you that's what it can mean man and I
strongly believe that I believe you have
got to have some higher power you've got
to you know I'm not saying you're wrong
if you don't well I here's what I'm
saying for me it helps
to not be out here alone it helps
because eventually the more I believe
that the less I feel like I'm by myself
and and that's a nice way to not feel
that's a nice way it's a nice way to
feel I mean to feel not alone you know
cuz that's all we all want we all want
to be you know loved we all want to be
accepted that's all we all want and by
having a higher power you know you
always have some feeling of acceptance
inside of you and some feeling of love
inside of you and that doesn't need to
be you know you can think you can call
that g.od you can call that it can be
anything anything you know doesn't have
to be of a specific denomination but you
hear me I think we're living this
opposite belief of what is true we think
that by serving ourselves we won't serve
ourselves so really by serving ourselves
we [ __ ] ourself over and we called
ourselves to meet you these are
addictions Wow so if we were all to
serve each other that we would feel full
man I I believe that that that that is
the recipe you know that is the recipe
to get out that because we've men I'll
tell you this dude when you wake up if
you to go do something for somebody else
and by the end of the day you're gonna
lay down and you'd be like what are you
gonna what he gonna feel bad no you
[ __ ] did something for somebody else
all day you're gonna feel good and
they're gonna feel loved and you're
gonna feel a sense of gratitude to
yourself for being a decent human yeah
not just not gonna feel probably good
for being a good person you're gonna
feel good for being a good human you
know part of the bigger hole it's
interesting that was a great call
I appreciate that call I really do we
have one more email that came in and I
wanted to just read a little bit of that
and this is from a 405 number it says I
changed my life your ha yeah says your
podcast helped me enjoy my life you say
you talk about overcoming the dark arts
I think the dark arts live within every
one of us we waste our time on social
media gossip
constantly and hardly help others
because of the self-centered
self-serving nature of this good old US
of A I would have been I would include
most modernized countries in that
category as well but I wanted to say
good old US of A my point is that every
day you wake up in the morning is an
opportunity to live a better life than
you have previously been living you
don't change by reading books by
watching documentaries or talking
philosophy with people you change by
taking action you change when you make
changes in your habits it is that simple
and it is that hard and that's a
beautiful thing man that's a beautiful
statement right there and I appreciate
that you know I appreciate that you know
it's a it's about taking action you know
you cannot think your way into positive
action but you can act your way into
positive thinking you know I've said it
before and I'll say it again and someone
said it to me one time you know so if
you got a dark art that's a real
affliction out there I know we've
covered some in this that were fun and
some that we're not you know but if you
got a dark art that was a real
affliction out there something that's
just just just nipping at you and you
can't shake it
just take that next step and make it
make it an action and a step is an
action it's not a thought take that next
step you know take that next positive
action you know take action do something
move act on that dark heart strike a
match you know lighting that dark art up
you know if you're being naughty with
your friend's mother being naughty with
chant just recognize at least what
you're going on what's going on in your
life make it as long as you're not
Viktor as long as you're not addicted to
it know that you're in control of what's
going on with you and if you feel out of
control then take some control man be a
control cat be a that's a control cat be
a control cat you know because you
deserve it
you know stay busy serve yourself you
know we got out here
you know we got out here we did some
things you know we shared we listened
you know and this is food we got the
holidays to be grateful you know fill
your belly but also fill your heart fill
your heart with a little bit of love for
yourself make sure you put two helpings
of that on your plate you know this is
time to be grateful you know don't get
don't get caught up the dark art who
talked about them now we can get into
them again later but for now we're gonna
be grateful be grateful you're alive be
grateful you have family around spend
time with them you hate them I don't
give up handcuff yourself to your nasty
uncle spend time with them they hate you
I don't give a double [ __ ] they hate
you I don't give a double up double
handcuff yourself to somebody who hates
you you know hit them with that love boy
cop them with that hitter beat him with
that aorta hit him with your heart show
them what's up show them who's boss man
I might do some things give him put that
out I don't know I don't know you know
it's gonna be a week to relax and
sometimes I want to relax you know I
made you something put it up on the
patreon page I don't know I think I
definitely owe some gratitude to my
patreon errs and I know it to all of you
guys and I'm sorry to just I'm not
trying to single them out but I want to
thank all you guys for all your love and
support from making this podcast cool
for keeping us going for keeping me
inspired you lift me up in so many ways
and make me feel a part of something
cool and you guys come out on the road
and I get to see a lot I meet a lot of
the people listen to the podcast
the call ends make me feel that I'm not
alone and some of the [ __ ] that I'm
going through and tonight I could have
just laid here again you know and not
taking care of myself and not been a
part of something but instead Here I am
you know Here I am for now we're in 25
minutes and we've been doing something
an hour and 34 it's gonna be the longest
one ever I promise will not go this long
again this
has been this past weekend Happy
Thanksgiving week to you love somebody
love yourself let it go man if there's
something on you let it go pray for your
enemies you hate somebody pray for them
boy dang you want to get somebody back
pray for them and I will take the hate
right out of your system I promise you
all right be good or be good at it you
can sleep pole to pole or hold a hole
but you can't sleep pole a hole that's
what they told me take care of brush
your hair be good to yourself because
you probably deserve it let's celebrate
living with Spencer with Spencer
Jacob growl thank you thank you thank
you here we go
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate me
[Music]
I'm about to go get a snicker at the
front desk take care of yourselves you
know love you creeps
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die